Buen día los partidos políticos y en
especial sus congresistas critican el
ultimátum lanzado por la presidenta Dina
boulván real parlamento la mayoría
coinciden que si la mandataria peruana
en realidad quiere elecciones inmediatas
la única salida es su renuncia desde la
izquierda se afirma que esperaban la
emisión de boluarte en su mensaje a los
peruanos y critican que la mandataria
peruana intente cargarle la
responsabilidad al parlamento Mientras
tanto desde la derecha existen
posiciones divididas Por una parte del
partido fujimorista fuerza popular apoya
los anuncios de la presidenta Dina
boluarte Mientras que otras agrupaciones
como renovación popular califican de
inaceptable que la mandataria peruana
haya amenazado al congreso con sus dos
iniciativas legislativas Jorge Montoya
uno de los líderes de esa agrupación
dijo que la presidenta boluarte Está
equivocada y que si continúa insistiendo
le aplicarán un proceso de impeachment o
vacancia presidencial y probabilidades
hay de que se apruebe la iniciativa de
adelantar las elecciones
para que la reforma de adelanto de
elecciones sea aprobada se requiere el
consenso de los congresistas y las
posiciones son muy marcadas y
polarizadas en ese sentido va a ser muy
difícil que se logren reunir los 87
votos que son necesarios para aprobar el
adelanto de elecciones y más aún cuando
la izquierda exige que se anexe la
convocatoria una asamblea Constituyente
posición que es rechazada por la derecha
a su vez la derecha se encuentra
dividida entre quienes apoyan la que las
elecciones se realicen este 2023 los
otros que piden que sea el 2024 ya
aquellos que quieren que las cosas
continúen Hasta el 2026 porque señalan
que sería inconstitucional recortar el
mandato al parlamento y también
irresponsable ceder ante las protestas